fasciné par l'armée depuis l'enfance
justin 18 ans est sur le point de
concrétiser son rêve devenir réserviste
dans l'armée de l'air
après une préparation militaire l'année
dernière elle a été sélectionné cette
année pour intégrer une finir formation
initiale militaire du réserviste au
programme ce matin sur la base aérienne
de tours c'est parcours d'obstacles et
malgré la difficulté justin est
satisfaite tri qu'ils venaient chercher
pendant cette lire la puissance au
niveau sport surtout c'est ça vous
entraînent beaucoup et qui va les cours
c'est tellement différent du monde civil
et alors que j'adore ça oui c'est pas
trop dur de temps en temps mais messi
n'ont a priori il ya des fois devant
entente on danse est beaucoup du coup
quand les autres derrière nous ça nous
pousse encore à continuer du sport pour
développer cohésion de groupe et
dépassement de soi mais le point d'orgue
de cette formation de cinq jours reste
avant tout le maniement d'une arme
réelle le famas alors avant le grand
jour
petit entraînement au tir à la carabine
c'est plus de la théorie qui est de la
sécurité sur les armes le maniement des
armes
et puis
et du coup toute sécurité en france la
réserve compte aujourd'hui 4250
réservistes d'ici l'année prochaine mais
les nouvelles recrues sont attendues
une montée en puissance de la réserve
qui s'explique par le contexte
antiterroriste objectif de l'avenir
former les nouveaux renforts de la
défense il ya un renforcement des
effectifs et une demande croissante
demande croissante dans le domaine de la
défense
c'est pour ça que parmi nos jeunes ici
sur le nombre présent jeu verne affecté
environ la moitié au profit des unités
de défense de là-bas derrière ces jeunes
à l'issue en suivant d'autres formations
seront intégrés au plan théâtre national
2019 qui permet de répondre aux besoins
exprimés par le gouvernement depuis
maintenant plus de deux ans pour le
moment les 28 mire de cette session
seront présentés au drapeau demain
officialisation de leur rentrée dans la
défense ils effectueront chacun cet été
vingt jours dans leur unité
d'affectation pour découvrir les 50
métiers de l'armée de l'air et pourquoi
pas l'occasion de susciter à ces jeunes
l'envi de s'engager